willkommen zurück bei "Understanding Quantum Information and Computation", mein Name ist John Watrous und ich bin der technische
Direktor für Bildung bei IBM Quantum. Dies ist die x-te Lektion der Reihe und die letzte Lektion in der
zweiten Einheit der Reihe, die sich mit Quantenalgorithmen beschäftigt. Wir haben über das Abfragemodell der Berechnung gesprochen, einschließlich Quanten-
algorithmen, die nachweisbare Vorteile gegenüber klassischen Algorithmen innerhalb dieses Modells bieten. Wir haben grundlegende Konzepte besprochen, die mit
Quantenalgorithmen zusammenhängen, und wie wir den Rechenaufwand messen können. In der vorherigen Lektion haben wir die Phasenschätzung und Shors
Algorithmus besprochen. In dieser Lektion werden wir Grovers Algorithmus besprechen, der einen quadratischen Vorteil von Quanten- gegenüber
klassischen Algorithmen bei sogenannten unstrukturierten Suchproblemen bietet, die ich beschreiben werde, sobald wir in die
Lektion einsteigen. Dies sind alles grundlegende Themen zu Quantenalgorithmen. Es gibt weitere Quanten-
algorithmen sowie allgemeine Paradigmen, die verschiedene Quantenalgorithmen und quantenalgorithmische Techniken vereinen, und
wenn du interessiert bist, empfehle ich dir, den Quantum Algorithm Zoo zu besuchen, der bekannte Quantenalgorithmen kategorisiert und viele Referenzen enthält
zu originalen Forschungsarbeiten, die zu ihrer Entwicklung beigetragen haben. Für diese Reihe jedoch
werden wir uns auf die Grundlagen beschränken, und beginnend mit der nächsten Lektion werden wir zu einem neuen Thema übergehen. Aber
zuerst lass uns über Grovers Algorithmus sprechen. Hier ist die Übersicht der Lektion: Wir beginnen mit einer kurzen Diskussion des
rechnerischen Problems, das wir angehen werden, nämlich der unstrukturierten Suche. Intuitiv gesprochen kannst du dir
das unstrukturierte Suchproblem als das Durchsuchen einer Sammlung von Elementen vorstellen, die nicht sortiert und nicht auf nützliche Weise geordnet wurde.
Dann werden wir Grovers Algorithmus besprechen, einen Quantenalgorithmus, der einen quadratischen Vorteil gegenüber
klassischen Algorithmen bietet – was das genau bedeutet, werden wir gleich erläutern. Eine sehr allgemeine Beschreibung davon,
wie dieser Algorithmus funktioniert, ist folgende: Zunächst gibt es einen Initialisierungsschritt, dann eine Operation, die ich als die
Grover-Operation bezeichne, die eine bestimmte Anzahl von Malen iteriert wird, und schließlich findet eine Messung statt, die einen Kandidaten
für die Lösung des Suchproblems aufdeckt. Ich werde erklären, was die Grover-Operation ist und wie sie
auf einem Quantencomputer implementiert werden kann. Dann werden wir eine Analyse dieser Operation durchgehen, um besser zu verstehen, was sie tut und warum sie für die
Suche nützlich ist. Der dritte Teil der Lektion befasst sich mit der Anzahl der Iterationen
in Grovers Algorithmus, also der Anzahl der Male, die die Grover-Operation angewendet werden sollte, vorausgesetzt, dass wir
die Wahrscheinlichkeit maximieren möchten, dass der Algorithmus erfolgreich das findet, wonach wir suchen, während wir gleichzeitig die Kosten minimieren.
Wir beginnen mit dem eindeutigen Suchproblem, einem Spezialfall, in dem es genau eine Lösung für unser
Suchproblem gibt, und dann überlegen wir, was passiert, wenn es mehrere Lösungen gibt. Abschließend werde ich die
Lektion mit einigen kurzen Anmerkungen zu Grovers Algorithmus und seinen Verallgemeinerungen beenden. Beginnen wir mit dem
rechnerischen Problem, das wir im Laufe der Lektion behandeln werden. Zunächst, wie wir es oft tun, werden wir
Sigma das binäre Alphabet bezeichnen lassen, und wir werden diese Notation für die gesamte Lektion verwenden, sodass ich nicht weiter
daran erinnern werde. Angenommen, wir haben eine Funktion f, die binäre Zeichenketten einer bestimmten Länge n auf
das binäre Alphabet abbildet. Unsere Annahme ist, dass wir diese Funktion leicht auswerten können,
zum Beispiel haben wir vielleicht einen booleschen circuit für diese Funktion, dessen Größe polynomiell in n ist. Das bedeutet aber nicht, dass dies
notwendigerweise eine einfache Funktion in irgendeinem Sinne ist, oder dass wir ein besonders gutes Verständnis dieser Funktion haben. Zum Beispiel haben wir vielleicht einen
eher komplizierten und unübersichtlichen booleschen circuit zur Berechnung von f, der es uns ermöglicht, ihn auf verschiedenen Eingabezeichenketten auszuwerten, aber nicht unbedingt eine
schöne Form hat, die darauf ausgelegt ist, uns das Leben zu erleichtern. Unser Ziel ist es, eine Lösung zu finden, womit wir
eine binäre Zeichenkette der Länge n meinen, die f zu eins auswertet. Im Allgemeinen ist dies ein sehr schwieriges
rechnerisches Problem, oder zumindest vermuten wir, dass es sehr schwierig ist. Insbesondere wenn die Eingabe tatsächlich die
Beschreibung eines booleschen circuits zur Berechnung der Funktion f ist, dann handelt es sich um ein sogenanntes NP-vollständiges Problem. Eine Möglichkeit,
dieses Problem zu formalisieren, ist als Abfrageproblem, und für die Zwecke dieser Lektion ist es sinnvoll,
dieses Problem rein im Kontext des Abfragemodells zu betrachten. Aber wenn wir darüber nachdenken, wo oder wann dieses
Problem in der Praxis auftreten könnte, ist es wohl natürlicher, f als durch einen booleschen
circuit berechnet zu betrachten. Wie wir in Lektion sechs gesehen haben, können wir diese beiden Sichtweisen durch die Konstruktion verbinden, die wir für das Umwandeln eines booleschen circuits durchgegangen sind, um
ihn in einen Quantum circuit zur Implementierung einer Abfrageoperation oder eines Abfrage-gate umzuwandeln. In jedem Fall, konzeptuell gesprochen,
ist die Eingabe des Problems diese Funktion f, und wir suchen nach einer Lösung, falls es eine gibt. Und falls
es keine Lösung gibt, das heißt, falls f sich als die konstante Null-Funktion herausstellt, dann ist die richtige Ausgabe, zu melden,
dass es keine Lösungen gibt. Dies ist ein unstrukturiertes Suchproblem in dem Sinne, dass es
nichts Besonderes an f gibt, das es leicht macht, eine Lösung zu finden. Es ist nicht so, als würden wir
Daten durchsuchen, die bereits geordnet wurden oder in eine Datenstruktur geladen wurden, die die Suche erleichtert, und es gibt kein Versprechen über die
Funktion f, das uns helfen könnte. Eine Möglichkeit, darüber nachzudenken, ist, dass es wie das Suchen nach einer bestimmten
Telefonnummer in einem Telefonbuch ist, im Gegensatz zur Suche nach einem Namen, was viel einfacher ist, vorausgesetzt, die Namen wurden
alphabetisch geordnet. In der Praxis geht es nicht wirklich darum, Daten zu durchsuchen,
die wir dazu neigen, so zu organisieren und zu speichern, dass die Suche leicht ist. Es ist eher repräsentativ für die Suche nach einer
Lösung für eine komplizierte Gleichung, zum Beispiel, oder vielleicht für die Suche nach der Kombination, die ein
Schloss öffnet. Nebenbei ist es sinnvoll, dieses Problem im Kontext des Abfragemodells zu betrachten, unabhängig davon, wie wir
über die praktische Relevanz dieses Modells denken. Natürlich gibt es in der realen Welt keine Orakel oder Black Boxes, aber bis wir
das Gegenteil erfahren, sind komplizierte und mysteriöse boolesche circuits irgendwie wie Black
Boxes. Jetzt lass uns über Algorithmen zur Lösung dieses unstrukturierten Suchproblems nachdenken, und das werden wir
im Abfragemodell tun, einfach der Einfachheit halber. Wenn wir einen booleschen circuit für unsere Funktion haben anstatt einer Black Box,
dann können wir immer noch Abfragealgorithmen darauf ausführen, aber natürlich können wir die Möglichkeit nicht ausschließen, dass ein neuer Algorithmus
für dieses Problem entdeckt wird, der nicht auf dem Stellen von Abfragen basiert. Aber damit werden wir uns nicht beschäftigen.
Zunächst nur ein bisschen Notation: Die Gesamtzahl der Eingabezeichenketten der Funktion f ist 2 hoch
kleines n, wobei kleines n die Länge der Eingabestrings für F ist. Ab jetzt werde ich großes N für diese Zahl 2 hoch
kleines n verwenden. Es ist ziemlich verbreitet, dass man einen Großbuchstaben nutzt, um zwei hoch die Potenz des Kleinbuchstabens
dieser Variable zu bezeichnen. Wir werden sehr häufig über die Zahl großes N sprechen, daher wird das einfach
praktisch sein und die Dinge etwas übersichtlicher halten. Diese Notation gilt für
die gesamte Lektion. Natürlich können wir das Suchproblem klassisch lösen, indem wir einfach
alle möglichen n-Bit-Strings in beliebiger Reihenfolge durchiterieren und F auf jedem davon auswerten.
Wenn wir dabei eine Lösung finden, können wir aufhören. Im schlimmsten Fall werden wir F jedoch auf jedem einzelnen
Eingabestring auswerten, was n – also großes N –
Abfragen erfordert. Wir könnten die Kosten dieser Berechnung auch anders messen – nicht nur in der Anzahl der Abfragen, sondern die Anzahl der Abfragen
entspricht der Anzahl der Male, die wir die Funktion f auswerten müssen, und es ist vernünftig anzunehmen, dass die Auswertungen von f die Kosten
dieser Berechnung dominieren werden. Das ist tatsächlich das Beste, was wir mit einem deterministischen Algorithmus erreichen können.
Und das gilt wiederum im Kontext des Abfragemodells: Wenn wir jeden Eingabe-
string bis auf einen abgefragt haben und F bisher auf allen den Wert null angenommen hat, wie können wir sicher sein, dass der letzte
String keine Lösung ist? Die Antwort lautet: das können wir nicht. Im schlimmsten
Fall brauchen wir also alle n Abfragen. Wir könnten auch Zufälligkeit einsetzen, was einige geringfügige Verbesserungen bieten kann, etwa die Reduzierung der
erwarteten Anzahl an Abfragen, um eine Lösung zu finden, wenn eine existiert. Oder wir könnten effektiv Korrektheit
gegen eine Reduzierung der Abfragen eintauschen. Egal wie man es dreht und wendet, wir brauchen immer noch eine Anzahl von Abfragen, die linear
in N ist. Klassisch gesehen brauchen wir also eine lineare Anzahl von Abfragen – linear
in großem N. Grovers Algorithmus ist ein Quantenalgorithmus für die Suche, der das besser macht: Er benötigt nur bigo von der
Quadratwurzel von n Abfragen. Diese Abfragen erfolgen in Superposition, also ist es kein Zauberwerk, aber es
ist eine deutliche Verbesserung gegenüber dem klassisch Möglichen, und das ist das, was man unter einem quadratischen
Vorteil versteht. Kann dieser quadratische Vorteil von Quanten gegenüber Klassik in einen tatsächlichen Vorteil in einem praktischen
Sinne umgewandelt werden? Wahrscheinlich nicht so bald, aber in ferner Zukunft – wer weiß. Aber selbst wenn
Grovers Algorithmus niemals zu einem praktischen Vorteil beim Suchen führt, ist er dennoch ein wichtiger Teil
des Fundaments der Quantenalgorithmen, das es sich lohnt zu verstehen. Bevor wir zu Grovers Algorithmus selbst übergehen, müssen wir
kurz über sogenannte Phase-Query-Gates sprechen. Viele Quantenalgorithmen im Abfragemodell werden auf natürliche Weise
mithilfe von Phase-Query-Gates ausgedrückt, und wir werden sehen, dass Grovers Algorithmus ein spezifisches
Beispiel dafür ist. Fangen wir mit einem kurzen Überblick über gewöhnliche Query-Gates an. Für eine Funktion f der
Form, über die wir gesprochen haben, ist das Query-Gate UF auf Standardbasiszuständen definiert, wie auf dem
Bildschirm gezeigt. Für Superpositionen von Standardbasiszuständen ergibt sich die Wirkung durch Linearität, und es lohnt sich, uns daran zu erinnern,
dass wir aus einem booleschen circuit für f tatsächlich einen circuit für diese Operation UF bauen können, zu Kosten, die
linear in der Größe des booleschen circuits sind. Das Phase-Query-Gate für f hingegen, das wir mit
dem Namen ZF bezeichnen, funktioniert folgendermaßen. Insbesondere operiert dieses gate auf
kleines n qubits, im Gegensatz zu kleines n plus einem qubit, und es schiebt den Funktionswert automatisch
in die Phase, anstatt den Ausgabewert per XOR auf ein zusätzliches qubit zu schreiben, wie wir es bei
UF haben. Wenn wir also überlegen, was passiert, wenn wir Phase-Kickback auf ein UF-gate anwenden,
implementieren wir im Grunde einfach ein ZF-gate. Wir brauchen einen Minus-Zustand und es kostet eine
Auswertung von UF, aber wir bekommen den Minus-Zustand tatsächlich zurück und können ihn für den nächsten verwenden, wenn wir wollen, oder
wir können ihn einfach verwerfen. Das ist also, was ein Phase-Query-Gate ist. Wenn uns jetzt nur
ein Phase-Query-Gate ZF gegeben ist und das die einzige Art ist, wie wir Zugang zur Funktion f haben, dann können wir tatsächlich
kein UF-gate zurückgewinnen. Wenn wir jedoch eine kontrollierte Version von ZF haben, dann können wir
ein UF-gate konstruieren, und das überlasse ich dir als
Übungsaufgabe. Zusätzlich zum Phase-Query-Gate für die Funktion f brauchen wir auch ein Phase-Query-Gate für die n-Bit-
OR-Funktion, also mit anderen Worten die Funktion, die den Wert null annimmt, wenn ihr der Nullstring gegeben wird, und ansonsten
den Wert eins annimmt. Und explizit ist die Art, wie ZOR auf Standardbasiszuständen wirkt, auf dem
Bildschirm gezeigt. Dieses gate hat keine Abhängigkeit von der Funktion f, braucht also keine
Abfragen. Eine Möglichkeit, einen Quanten-circuit zu bauen, der diese Operation implementiert, besteht darin, etwas
Ähnliches zu tun wie bei der Funktion f, außer dass wir mit einem booleschen circuit beginnen, der die OR-Funktion auf
n Bits berechnet. Jetzt, da wir diese gates haben, können wir zum nächsten
Abschnitt übergehen. Nun besprechen wir Grovers Algorithmus, beginnend mit einer Beschreibung des Algorithmus. Wir beginnen damit, dass wir
kleine n qubits jeweils in den Plus-Zustand initialisieren, oder mit anderen Worten, wir bringen diese qubits in eine gleiche Superposition aller
Binärstrings der Länge n. Was wir tun werden, ist effektiv, den Zustand dieser qubits
in Richtung einer Lösung zu lenken. Es ist also intuitiv, dass wir in diesem Zustand starten, weil wir noch nichts über die Funktion f wissen.
Zu diesem Zeitpunkt ist jeder String gleich wahrscheinlich eine Lösung, und das spiegelt sich in der Tatsache wider, dass sich diese qubits in einer gleichen Superposition aller
Strings befinden. Dann iterieren wir: Wir wenden wiederholt die Grover-Operation an, die wirklich das Herzstück des
Algorithmus ist, und ich werde sie gleich beschreiben. Wir wenden diese Operation insgesamt T-mal an, wobei T eine nicht-negative
ganze Zahl ist. Diese Zahl wird vom Algorithmus selbst jedoch nicht festgelegt – wir müssen T irgendwie wählen. Im nächsten
Abschnitt werden wir über gute Wahlmöglichkeiten für T sprechen. Aber vorerst können wir diese Anzahl von Iterationen t als
beliebig betrachten. Und schließlich messen wir in der Standardbasis, was uns einen
Kandidaten für eine Lösung liefert. Es gibt keine Garantie, dass es eine Lösung ist, aber wenn wir T gut wählen, dann
kann die Wahrscheinlichkeit, eine Lösung zu erhalten, groß gemacht werden. Und hier ist die Grover-Operation
selbst, die wir G genannt haben. Sie ist eine Komposition von Operationen, alle auf N qubits, also ist das ein N-
qubit-Operation, zuerst haben wir ein ZF-gate oder mit anderen Worten ein Phasenabfrage-gate für die
Eingabefunktion f, gefolgt von einer Schicht Hadamard-gates, und dann haben wir Zor, das ist das Phasenabfrage-gate für die Or-
Funktion, und schließlich noch eine weitere Schicht Hadamard-gates. Wir sehen also, dass eine Iteration in
Schritt zwei durch einen circuit implementiert werden kann, der die hier auf dem Bildschirm gezeigte Form hat, und wir haben hier übrigens vier qubits
aber im Allgemeinen können wir eine beliebige Anzahl von qubits haben. Ein wichtiger Punkt ist, dass wir eine Abfrage von f benötigen, um G zu implementieren. Wir
benötigen eine Abfrage, um ZF zu implementieren, und keine der anderen Operationen ist von F abhängig, sie erfordern also keine Abfragen. Diese Zahl T, die
die Anzahl der Anwendungen von G in Schritt zwei darstellt, entspricht auch der Anzahl der Abfragen, die wir
benötigen. Hier ist eine typische Art, wie wir den Grover-Algorithmus verwenden könnten, aber das ist sicher nicht die einzige Möglichkeit, wie ich gesagt habe.
Zuerst müssen wir T wählen, und darauf gehen wir im nächsten Abschnitt ein.
Für welches T wir auch immer wählen, wir führen den Grover-Algorithmus für T Iterationen aus und erhalten eine Kandidatenlösung.
X. Es gibt keine Garantie, dass X wirklich eine Lösung ist, aber wir können eine zusätzliche Abfrage verwenden, um das zu überprüfen. Wenn wir eine Lösung haben, können wir
diese Lösung ausgeben und stoppen, andernfalls können wir es erneut versuchen, möglicherweise mit einer anderen Wahl von T,
aber nicht notwendigerweise, oder wir können aufgeben und melden, dass es keine Lösungen gibt. Wie ich schon gesagt habe, ist das
nicht die einzige Art, den Algorithmus zu verwenden, aber das ist eine natürliche Art, ihn auf das Suchproblem anzuwenden. Als nächstes sehen wir, was die Grover-
Operation tatsächlich mit dem Zustand der N qubits macht, auf die sie wirkt. Stellen wir uns unsere n qubits vor als
ein einzelnes Register, das ich Q nennen werde, nur um einen Namen zu wählen. Erinnere dich, was wir zuerst tun in
Grovers Algorithmus: wir bringen Q in eine gleichförmige Superposition aller n-Bit-Strings, und das tun wir, indem wir Hadamard-
gates auf n qubits im Null-Zustand anwenden. Wir iterieren dann die Grover-Operation G und
messen. Es wird hilfreich sein, die Menge aller n-Bit-Strings in zwei Mengen aufzuteilen: A z und
A1. A z enthält alle Strings, die bewirken, dass F zu null auswertet, und A1 enthält alle Strings, die bewirken, dass F
zu eins auswertet. Eine andere Möglichkeit, das zu sagen, ist, dass A1 alle Lösungen unserer Suche enthält.
Problem, während A z alle Nicht-Lösungen enthält. Wir werden besonders
an zwei Quantenzuständen interessiert sein. Einer ist die gleichförmige Superposition über alle Nicht-Lösungen, das ist ket A z, und der
andere ist gleichförmig über alle Lösungen, und das ist ket A1. Ich sollte darauf hinweisen, dass diese Definitionen nur
Sinn ergeben, wenn diese Mengen nicht leer sind, denn sonst summieren wir null Dinge auf und teilen durch null. Wenn wir
diese Analyse des Grover-Algorithmus durchführen, werden wir diese Annahme machen. Wir können sehr leicht herausfinden, was
der Grover-Algorithmus tut, wenn f entweder die konstante Null-Funktion oder die konstante Eins-Funktion ist, indem wir sie als Sonderfälle behandeln, aber ich werde das
dir überlassen, selbst zu erarbeiten. Wenig überraschend: wenn jeder String eine Lösung ist, werden wir tatsächlich eine
Lösung erhalten, wenn wir messen, und wenn es keine Lösungen gibt, werden wir keine erhalten, weil es in diesem Fall keine
gibt. Aber für diese Analyse nehmen wir an, dass beide Mengen nicht leer sind, sodass diese
Definitionen der beiden Zustände Sinn ergeben. Das ist übrigens eine ziemlich gebräuchliche
Notation: Wenn wir eine nicht leere endliche Menge S haben, können wir ket S schreiben, um die gleichförmige Superposition über die
Elemente dieser Menge zu bezeichnen, genau wie wir es hier haben. Also sammeln wir diese Definitionen so, und wir sehen, wie sie sich verbinden
mit dem Grover-Algorithmus. Der erste Schritt des Grover-Algorithmus ist der Initialisierungsschritt, der Q in eine gleich förmige
Superposition über alle n-Bit-Strings bringt, und nur um diesem Zustand einen leicht erkennbaren Namen zu geben, werde ich ihn
ket u nennen. U ist kurz für uniform. Für die Analyse ist es wichtig, dass wir zunächst festhalten, dass
dieser gleichförmige Zustand ket u im Unterraum liegt, der von den zwei Vektoren ket A0 und ket
A1 aufgespannt wird. Wenn wir insbesondere die Linearkombination dieser beiden Zustände nehmen, die hier auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt wird, erhalten wir ket
u. Der Schlüssel zur gesamten Analyse ist nun die Tatsache, dass der Zustand von Q in
diesem zweidimensionalen Unterraum verbleibt, egal wie oft wir die Grover-Operation anwenden. Also läuft alles darauf hinaus,
was in einem zweidimensionalen Unterraum passiert. Schauen wir uns nun an, was die Grover-Operation tut, und insbesondere was sie
mit Vektoren im zweidimensionalen Unterraum macht, der von ket A0 und ket
A1 aufgespannt wird. Es ist hilfreich, sich vorzustellen, dass G in zwei Teile aufgeteilt ist. Ein Teil ist das ZF-
gate und der andere Teil ist das Zor-gate, eingebettet zwischen zwei Schichten Hadamard-
gates. Hier ist die Definition von ZF von vorhin, und aus dieser Definition ist es ziemlich einfach zu sehen, dass seine
Wirkung auf unsere zwei Zustände, die gleichförmigen Superpositionen von Nicht-Lösungen und Lösungen, einfach darin besteht, ein Minuszeichen
vor ket A1 zu setzen. Mit ket A0 passiert nichts, und das ist alles, was wir wirklich wissen müssen
über ZF für diese Analyse. Für den zweiten Teil, der
das Zor-gate ist, eingebettet zwischen zwei Schichten Hadamard-gates, erinnern wir uns zunächst daran, wie Zor definiert ist. Eine Möglichkeit, es zu schreiben,
ist wie auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt. Das ist derselbe Ausdruck wie zuvor, und eine andere Möglichkeit, ihn mit der Dirac-
Notation auszudrücken, ist wie folgt, und du kannst diesen Ausdruck überprüfen, indem du dir überlegst, wie die Operation auf der
rechten Seite auf Standardbasisstände wirkt. Insbesondere tut sie nichts mit dem Null-Zustand, und jeder
andere Standardbasiszustand bekommt ein Minuszeichen, was mit der Definition von Z
or übereinstimmt. Wenn wir diese Operation zwischen zwei Schichten Hadamard-gates einbetten, erhalten wir einen ähnlichen Ausdruck, außer
dass wir anstelle des Null-Standardbasiszustands jetzt unsere gleichförmige Superposition ket u haben, und das liegt daran, dass H tensor
n den L-Null-Standardbasiszustand in ket u transformiert, und außerdem ist H tensor n sein eigenes konjugiertes Transposiertes, sodass es auf ähnliche Weise
von rechts auf das bra wirkt, anstatt auf das ket. Und jetzt werden wir herausfinden,
was G mit unseren zwei Vektoren A0 und A1 macht, anhand der Fakten, die wir gerade
festgestellt haben. Beginnen wir mit A0. Zunächst setzen wir den Ausdruck ein,
den wir für das Zor-gate eingebettet zwischen zwei Schichten Hadamard-gates erhalten haben. Als nächstes können wir die Tatsache nutzen, dass ZF nichts
mit ket A z macht, sodass wir die ZF-Operation weglassen können. Und jetzt können wir mit der Beschreibung
von ket u, die wir hier oben haben, zusammen mit der Tatsache, dass ket A0 und ket A1 orthogonale Einheitsvektoren sind, berechnen
das Produkt dieses Bra hier und dieses Kets, und was wir erhalten, ist die Quadratwurzel der Anzahl der Nicht-Lösungen
dividiert durch n. Wir können diese Tatsache nutzen, um auszuwerten, was wir erhalten, und indem wir unseren Ausdruck für Ket U einsetzen und
vereinfachen, erhalten wir das Endergebnis, das hier auf dem Bildschirm zu sehen ist. Beachte insbesondere, dass dieser
Vektor im zweidimensionalen Unterraum enthalten ist, der von K a0 und K A1 aufgespannt wird, wie ich zuvor angedeutet habe, und
außerdem sind die Koeffizienten zufällig reelle Zahlen. Überprüfe das wie immer in
deinem eigenen Tempo, wenn du das möchtest. Ich neige dazu, solche Dinge in diesen Videos schnell durchzugehen, mit der
Erwartung, dass du das Video pausierst, um darüber nachzudenken, wenn du das möchtest. Also lass uns das bereinigen, damit wir
das Endergebnis für später speichern können, und jetzt werden wir etwas Ähnliches für den Vektor k
A1 machen. Wir können denselben Ausdruck für G wie zuvor verwenden, und diesmal fügt das ZF gate
ein Minuszeichen ein, was hier dadurch widergespiegelt wird, dass wir die beiden Terme in der Operation in
Klammern vertauscht haben. Wir gehen dann auf sehr ähnliche Weise vor, und das Endergebnis ist ähnlich, außer dass die beiden Koeffizienten
vertauscht sind und wir jetzt ein Minuszeichen vor einem von ihnen haben, was einfach so ist, wie die Algebra aufgeht. Und wieder kannst du
das in deinem eigenen Tempo überprüfen. Beachte, dass wir erneut eine reelle Linearkombination unserer beiden Vektoren K a0 und
K A1 haben. Wir werden auch diesen bereinigen und das Endergebnis mit dem anderen zusammenfügen, und jetzt können wir sehen, wie G
auf den Unterraum wirkt, der von unseren beiden Vektoren aufgespannt wird. Eine Möglichkeit, das zu tun, besteht darin, es in Form der 2x2-Matrix M auszudrücken, die
hier auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt wird. Und nur um klarzustellen, was wir hier tun: Wir ordnen die erste Zeile und die erste
Spalte K a0 zu und die zweite Zeile und Spalte Kat A1. Bisher haben wir in der Reihe wirklich
nur Matrizen verwendet, um die Wirkungsweise von Operationen auf Standard-Basiszustände zu beschreiben. Es ist jedoch üblich, Matrizen zu verwenden,
um die Wirkung linearer Abbildungen auf verschiedene Mengen von Vektoren zu beschreiben, nicht nur auf Standard-Basiszustände. Und hier sprechen wir darüber, was die Operation G mit
den Vektoren K a0 und K A1 macht. Wir können mehr darüber sagen, was G mit Vektoren im
Span von K a0 und K A1 macht, wenn wir uns diese Matrix M genauer ansehen, und insbesondere werden wir feststellen, dass
M eine Rotationsmatrix ist, was bedeutet, dass ihre Wirkung auf diesen zweidimensionalen Raum als Rotation um einen
festen Winkel beschrieben werden kann. Es gibt ein paar verschiedene Möglichkeiten, das zu sehen, und eine besteht darin, zu beobachten,
dass diese Matrix M als Quadrat einer Matrix ausgedrückt werden kann, die etwas einfacher aussieht. Das mag schwer zu erkennen sein, wenn
wir uns M alleine anschauen, aber das ist nichts, was wir selbst herausfinden müssen. Wir müssen es nur überprüfen, und das können wir tun, indem wir einfach
die Matrix auf der rechten Seite quadrieren. Eine andere Möglichkeit, die Matrix auf der rechten Seite ohne das Quadrat zu schreiben, ist
auf dem Bildschirm zu sehen, und das ist die typische Weise, eine Rotation um einen gegebenen Winkel Theta als
Matrix zu beschreiben. Der genaue Winkel, um den wir rotieren, ist zufällig der Arkussinus der Quadratwurzel der Anzahl der
Lösungen dividiert durch n. Und übrigens, da wir das zum ersten Mal sehen, möchte ich darauf hinweisen, dass
dieser Winkel sehr wichtig ist. Er wird immer wieder auftauchen, während wir mit dieser
Analyse fortfahren. Das Argument des Arkussinus ist eine Zahl zwischen 0 und 1, und insbesondere ist die Art, wie wir
den Arkussinus hier interpretieren, dass es der Winkel zwischen 0 und Pi / 2 ist, der uns das Argument liefert, wenn wir
den Sinus nehmen. Das ist also eine Möglichkeit, über diese Matrix nachzudenken, die wir quadriert haben, um
M zu erhalten. Und da das Quadrieren der Matrix dasselbe ist wie das zweimalige Anwenden, sehen wir, dass M alternativ als eine
Rotation nicht um einen Winkel von Theta, sondern um zwei * Theta geschrieben werden kann, weil wir durch das Quadrieren um einen Winkel von Theta
zweimal rotieren. Eine andere Möglichkeit, all das zu überprüfen, übrigens, falls es hilfreich ist, besteht darin, mit diesem Endausdruck von M
zu beginnen und die Doppelwinkelformeln aus der Trigonometrie zu verwenden, um den ursprünglichen Ausdruck von
M zu erhalten. Und das ist der Ausdruck von M, der die Wirkung beschreibt, die g auf den Unterraum hat, der von K a0 und K A1 aufgespannt wird. Das wird
am nützlichsten sein für die weitere Arbeit. Nun zurück zu Grover's Algorithmus selbst: nach dem
Initialisierungsschritt, aber bevor wir irgendwelche Anwendungen von G durchführen, ist der Zustand unseres n-qubit-Registers Q Katu, die
gleichmäßige Superposition über alle n-Bit-Strings. Und hier haben wir denselben Ausdruck von Kat u in Bezug auf K a0 und
K A1 wie zuvor, aber jetzt, da wir diesen Winkel Theta identifiziert haben, sehen wir, dass wir
k u alternativ als Kosinus Theta * k a 0 plus Sinus Theta * K
A1 schreiben könnten. Das ist klar für den Koeffizienten von K A1, und für den anderen Koeffizienten müssen wir nur beobachten, dass die Größe von a0 plus
die Größe von A1 gleich n ist, und dann können wir es aus einigen grundlegenden trigonometrischen Überlegungen ableiten. Das ist also der Zustand, mit dem wir
beginnen, und beim ersten Mal, wenn wir G anwenden, rotieren wir um einen Winkel von 2 * Theta, sodass der Gesamtwinkel 3 *
Theta wird. Und wenn wir G erneut anwenden, steigt der Winkel auf 5 Theta, weil wir effektiv um einen zusätzlichen
Winkel von 2 Theta rotiert haben. Und so weiter. Nach T Anwendungen von G können wir den
erhaltenen Zustand darstellen, wie auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt, wobei der Winkel unseres Zustands gleich 2T + 1 * Theta ist. Das sind 2 * Theta
für jede Anwendung von G, zusammen mit einem zusätzlichen Theta, weil das der Zustand ist, mit dem wir begonnen haben.
Wir können auch über die Wirkung der Grover-Operation in geometrischen Begriffen nachdenken, und das hilft, etwas Licht darauf zu werfen, wie
sie funktioniert und warum ihr Effekt darin besteht, den Zustand des Registers Q zu rotieren. Hier ist die Hauptidee: die Grover-
Operation ist eine Zusammensetzung der zwei Teile, die wir bereits identifiziert haben. Einer ist ZF und der andere ist z oder send zwischen
zwei Schichten von Hadamard gates. Diese zwei Teile sind
Spiegelungen, und wenn wir zwei Spiegelungen zusammensetzen, erhalten wir eine Rotation. Also lass uns sehen, wie das im
Detail funktioniert. Konzentrieren wir uns zuerst auf ZF, und wir werden unsere Aufmerksamkeit auf den
gleichen zweidimensionalen Unterraum beschränken, über den wir gesprochen haben, also den, der von Kat a0 und Kat
A1 aufgespannt wird. Wie wir bereits beobachtet haben, ist die Wirkung von ZF auf diesen Raum recht einfach: es tut
nichts mit Kat a z und setzt ein Minuszeichen vor K A1. Das ist eine Spiegelung, und insbesondere
ist es eine Spiegelung um die Gerade parallel zu K a0, die wir L1 nennen werden, nur um ihr einen
Namen zu geben. Um zu sehen, warum es eine Spiegelung ist, hilft es, ein Bild zu zeichnen. Hier haben wir unsere beiden Vektoren K
a0 und K A1, die orthogonale Einheitsvektoren sind, und wir können uns den Bildschirm als bestehend aus allen reellen
Linearkombinationen dieser beiden Vektoren, also repräsentiert der Kreis alle Einheitsvektoren, für die die Koeffizienten von
diesen beiden Vektoren reelle Zahlen sind. Hier ist die Gerade L1, die parallel zu K a0 ist, und wenn wir einen
beliebigen Vektor s auf diesem Kreis betrachten, dann bewirkt die Anwendung von ZF eine Spiegelung an dieser Geraden, wie auf dem
Bildschirm dargestellt – einfach weil wir k a z unverändert lassen und ein Minuszeichen vor K
A1 setzen. Im Sonderfall, dass s gleich k a null ist, passiert zum Beispiel nichts, wenn wir diese Spiegelung durchführen, und wenn s
K A1 ist, führt die Spiegelung uns bis zu negativem K A1, was mit der Wirkung von ZF übereinstimmt. ZF ist also eine
Spiegelung, die sich wie hier visualisieren lässt. Der zweite Teil von G, nämlich z, der
zwischen zwei Schichten von Hadamard gates eingebettet ist, lässt sich als 2 * K Bru minus die Einheitsmatrix ausdrücken, wie wir
bereits gesehen haben, und auch dies ist eine Spiegelung – diesmal an der Geraden L2 parallel zu k u anstatt K
a0. Wir können diese Operation ähnlich wie ZF visualisieren. Hier ist der Vektor k
hypothetisch, also ist dies die Gerade L2 parallel zu K, und die Wirkung auf einen beliebigen Vektor S ist erneut, ihn
an der Geraden zu spiegeln, die in diesem Fall L2 ist.
Und schließlich: Wie ich bereits erwähnt habe, ergibt die Hintereinanderausführung zweier Spiegelungen stets eine Rotation, und zwar
eine Rotation um das Doppelte des Winkels zwischen den Spiegelungsgeraden. Zeichnen wir also ein ähnliches
Bild wie zuvor: Hier sind die Spiegelungsgeraden mit dem Winkel Theta zwischen
ihnen, und wenn wir einen beliebigen Vektor s an der ersten Geraden L1 und
dann an der zweiten Geraden L2 spiegeln, ist der Nettoeffekt eine Rotation des Vektors s um den Winkel 2 * Theta.
Das gilt allgemein, und du kannst es an weiteren eigenen Beispielen ausprobieren, um zu sehen, dass dies tatsächlich so funktioniert.
Hoffentlich hilft dir das, ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, warum die Grover-Operation den Effekt hat, Vektoren zu rotieren.
Als nächstes wenden wir uns der Frage zu, wie man die Anzahl der Iterationen T in Grovers
Algorithmus wählt. Lass uns damit beginnen, zu überlegen, wie die bisherige Analyse, die zeigt, was die Grover-Operation bewirkt,
wenn wir sie wiederholt auf die gleichmäßige Superposition anwenden, mit der Aufgabe zusammenhängt, die wir lösen wollen – nämlich eine Lösung für unser Suchproblem zu finden.
Oder mit anderen Worten: irgendeine Zeichenkette aus der Menge A1. Kurz gesagt werden wir im Wesentlichen ein Ziel setzen
und dann herausfinden, wie oft wir die Grover-Operation anwenden müssen, um dem Ziel nahe zu kommen.
Stell dir zunächst vor, wir haben irgendeinen Zustand, der eine Linearkombination unserer beiden Vektoren K a0 und K
A1 ist. Wenn wir auf diesen Zustand eine Standardbasismessung durchführen, erhalten wir ein Ergebnis aus der Menge A1 – das ist
die Menge der Lösungen unseres Suchproblems – mit einer Wahrscheinlichkeit gleich dem Betragsquadrat des Koeffizienten von K A1. Für den
auf dem Bildschirm gezeigten Vektor ist dieser Koeffizient beta. Das ist intuitiv: Würden wir den Zustand K a0 messen,
erhielten wir eine zufällige Nicht-Lösung, und wenn wir K A1 messen würden, erhielten wir eine zufällige Lösung. Wenn wir also diesen Zustand
hier messen, erhalten wir mit Wahrscheinlichkeit Betragsquadrat von Alpha eine zufällige Nicht-Lösung und mit Wahrscheinlichkeit
Betragsquadrat von beta eine zufällige Lösung. Wir können uns aber auch einen Moment nehmen, um es hier auszurechnen – hier ist der Zustand ausgeschrieben,
sodass wir die Einträge dieses Vektors für Standardbasis-Zustände sehen können. Wenn wir also messen, sind das die
Wahrscheinlichkeiten für jedes mögliche Ergebnis, und um die Wahrscheinlichkeit zu erhalten, eine Lösung zu bekommen, summieren wir die
Wahrscheinlichkeiten für alle möglichen Lösungen, was uns das Betragsquadrat von beta ergibt, wie
erwartet. Wir haben bereits analysiert, was passiert, wenn wir Grovers Algorithmus für T Iterationen ausführen: Wir erhalten den Zustand,
der hier auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt wird. Da der Koeffizient von K A1 der Sinus
von (2T + 1) * Theta ist – wobei hier wieder dieser sehr wichtige Winkel Theta vorkommt –
sehen wir eine Lösung mit Wahrscheinlichkeit sin²((2T + 1) *
Theta). Wir möchten diese Wahrscheinlichkeit groß machen, idealerweise so nah wie möglich an eins. Während wir also den Zustandsvektor durch Iteration von G rotieren,
betrachten wir K A1 als Zielzustand und versuchen,
T so zu wählen, dass wir nahe an diesen Zustand gelangen. Dabei sollten wir im Hinterkopf behalten, dass wir auch
T minimieren möchten, da das die Anzahl der Abfragen ist, die wir stellen müssen. Wenn wir also diese
Wahrscheinlichkeit nahe an eins bringen und T minimieren wollen, ergibt es Sinn, den Winkel unseres Zustandsvektors nahe Pi / 2 zu machen, weil
das der kleinste Winkel ist, der das Quadrat des Sinus groß macht. Es ist also im Wesentlichen unsere erste Möglichkeit, die Wahrscheinlichkeit groß zu machen, während wir
den Zustandsvektor rotieren. Nun können wir diesen Winkel Pi / 2 nicht unbedingt exakt treffen, weil T
eine ganze Zahl sein muss. Aber wenn wir es näherungsweise betrachten und t auflösen, als wäre es eine Ungleichung, sehen wir, dass idealerweise
T gleich Pi / 4 * Theta minus 1/2 zu wählen
sinnvoll ist. Aber da T natürlich eine nichtnegative ganze Zahl sein muss, nehmen wir
die nächste ganze Zahl zu diesem idealen Wert, also den Floor von Pi dividiert durch 4 *
Theta. Den Floor zu nehmen bedeutet übrigens einfach, den Nachkommaanteil wegzuwerfen – mit anderen Worten ist es die größte
ganze Zahl, die kleiner oder gleich dem Ausdruck ist, von dem wir den Floor nehmen. Gemäß diesem Ausdruck: wenn der
ideale Wert genau zwischen zwei ganzen Zahlen liegt, runden wir auf – aber das spielt für
diese Lektion überhaupt keine Rolle. Also konzentrieren wir uns im Folgenden auf diese spezielle Wahl von
T. Es gibt jedoch noch eine weitere wichtige Überlegung, nämlich dass diese Festlegung von T davon abhängt,
wie viele Lösungen es gibt, weil der Winkel Theta von der Anzahl der
Lösungen abhängt. Im Folgenden werde ich den Buchstaben s verwenden, um die Anzahl der Lösungen zu bezeichnen – also die Größe der
Menge A1 –, einfach der Bequemlichkeit halber. Der Punkt ist jedenfalls, dass unser
Ausdruck für T, den Wert, von dem wir annehmen, dass er gut ist, von Theta abhängt, und Theta von S abhängt, also von
der Größe der Menge A1. Das ist kein Problem, wenn wir im Voraus wissen, wie viele Lösungen es gibt. Aber
wenn wir die Anzahl der Lösungen nicht im Voraus kennen, wissen wir nicht, was Theta ist, und können T nicht so wählen
und müssen etwas anderes tun. Ich komme etwas später auf den Fall zurück, in dem wir s nicht kennen. Zunächst aber
konzentrieren wir uns auf die Situation, in der wir die Anzahl der Lösungen kennen – beginnend mit der eindeutigen Suche.
wo es garantiert genau eine eindeutige Lösung gibt, die wir suchen
Ich habe das eindeutige Suchproblem als Beispiel für ein Abfrageproblem in Lektion
fünf erwähnt. Die Eingabe ist eine Funktion f von n Bits auf ein Bit. Es gibt einen eindeutigen n-Bit-
String, der bewirkt, dass F zu eins ausgewertet wird, und das Ziel ist, diesen String auszugeben. Also
ist das äquivalent zum unstrukturierten Suchproblem, über das wir gesprochen haben, aber mit der Zusicherung, dass es genau eine Lösung gibt, und tatsächlich ist das
die einzige Version des Suchproblems, die Lov Grover in seinem ursprünglichen Paper von 1996 betrachtet hat, das Grovers
Algorithmus einführte. Für die eindeutige Suche gilt, dass s gleich 1 ist, und daher ist dieser wichtige Winkel Theta gleich dem inversen Sinus
der Quadratwurzel von 1/n. Wenn n groß ist, ist dieser Wert ungefähr die Quadratwurzel von 1/N, und
das liegt daran, dass für immer kleinere Winkel die Sinusfunktion immer mehr wie die Identität
aussieht. Wenn wir diese Näherung in unsere Wahl für T einsetzen, sehen wir, dass T ungefähr dem Floor
von pi durch 4 mal der Quadratwurzel von n entspricht. Das ist gut, denn wir sind auf dem richtigen Weg, Big O der Quadratwurzel von n
Abfragen zu verwenden. Aber an diesem Punkt haben wir noch nicht genau untersucht, wie gut der Algorithmus
abschneidet. Schauen wir uns ein Beispiel an, bei dem N gleich 128 ist, was 2 hoch 7 ist. Also
ist unsere Funktion f von sieben Bits auf ein Bit, und wir gehen davon aus, dass es eine eindeutige Lösung gibt. Aber um herauszufinden, wie
gut der Algorithmus funktioniert, müssen wir uns wirklich nur mit dem Winkel Theta befassen, den wir berechnen können. Er beträgt
ungefähr 0,0885 Radiant, was etwas mehr als 5° ist, und wenn wir diesen Wert in unseren
Ausdruck für T einsetzen, erhalten wir acht. Wir überlegen also, was passiert, wenn wir nach einer eindeutigen Lösung unter 128
Möglichkeiten mit acht Abfragen suchen. Wir können eine Abbildung zeichnen, um zu zeigen, wie sich der Zustand im Laufe der
Zeit verändert, während wir Iterationen der Grover-Operation durchführen. Wie zuvor haben wir die Zustände K
a0 und K A1, und in diesem speziellen Fall, also bei der eindeutigen Suche, ist K A1 tatsächlich der Standardbasisvektor,
der der eindeutigen Lösung entspricht, was auch immer sie ist. K a0 hingegen ist die gleichmäßige Superposition über alle
Strings außer der eindeutigen Lösung. Hier ist die gleichmäßige Superposition über alle Strings, die wir
als Kosinus Theta mal K a0 plus Sinus Theta mal K A1 schreiben können, und es ist sinnvoll, dass K a0
und K U in diesem Fall nahe beieinander sind, denn wie wir gerade festgestellt haben, ist K a0
fast die gleichmäßige Superposition über alle Strings – es fehlt nur ein einziger String, nämlich die eindeutige Lösung. G erneut anzuwenden, rotiert um
weitere 2 Theta. Also sind wir hier nach zwei Iterationen. Hier sind drei, 4, 5, 6, 7 und 8.
Und nun sehen wir, dass wir K A1 ziemlich nahe sind. Wenn wir also jetzt anhalten und messen, werden wir sehr wahrscheinlich
die eindeutige Lösung erhalten. Und tatsächlich besteht in diesem Fall nur eine Chance von etwa einem halben Prozent, dass wir die eindeutige
Lösung nicht erhalten. Wenn wir andererseits die Grover-Operation öfter als die empfohlenen acht Mal anwenden würden,
würde die Wahrscheinlichkeit, eine Lösung zu erhalten, wieder sinken, und mit der Zeit würde sie oszillieren, da der Zustand sich im Kreis dreht.
Also ist es wichtig, die Iterationen zum richtigen Zeitpunkt zu stoppen, wenn wir mit hoher
Wahrscheinlichkeit Erfolg haben wollen. Überlegen wir, wie hoch die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist, dass unsere Wahl von T die eindeutige Lösung aufdeckt – allgemeiner für verschiedene Werte von
n. Wir schreiben pn1, um die Wahrscheinlichkeit zu bezeichnen, dass Grovers Algorithmus erfolgreich eine eindeutige Lösung findet,
für jeden möglichen Wert von n. Die Eins steht für eine Lösung, und wir werden diese Notation auf andere Anzahlen von Lösungen
gleich ausweiten. Hier ist eine Tabelle dieser Wahrscheinlichkeiten für kleine Zweierpotenzen. Sie beginnt mit N gleich 2 und die
Wahrscheinlichkeit ist 1/2, was nicht besonders gut ist. Aber dann ist für N gleich 4 die Wahrscheinlichkeit genau eins, also funktioniert es
in diesem Fall perfekt. Es ist übrigens eine tolle Übung, explizit durchzuarbeiten, wie diese beiden Fälle funktionieren,
insbesondere der Fall, dass n gleich vier ist. In diesem Fall suchen wir nach einer Lösung unter vier Möglichkeiten.
Wir benötigen nur eine einzige Abfrage, und es funktioniert perfekt. Wenn n größer wird, sehen wir einige Schwankungen – die Wahrscheinlichkeiten
gehen etwas rauf und runter, aber sie scheinen sich eins anzunähern, und das stimmt tatsächlich. Es lässt sich
analytisch beweisen, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit immer mindestens 1 - 1/n beträgt. Das ist gut.
Der Algorithmus ist nicht perfekt – es ist nicht garantiert, dass wir eine Lösung bekommen, aber es ist recht wahrscheinlich, insbesondere für große
Werte von n sowie die sehr interessante Anomalie, die auftritt, wenn n gleich 4 ist.
Ich sollte auch darauf hinweisen, dass wir den gesamten Algorithmus einschließlich der Messungen beliebig oft ausführen können, und wenn auch nur einer der Durchläufe
erfolgreich ist, erhalten wir eine Lösung. Wenn diese Wahrscheinlichkeiten also nicht gut genug sind, können wir sie leicht erhöhen, indem wir einfach
den Algorithmus erneut ausführen. Selbst wenn diese Wahrscheinlichkeiten alle gleich 1/2 wären, hätten wir immer noch einen
nützlichen Suchalgorithmus. Überlegen wir nun, was passiert, wenn es mehrere
Lösungen gibt. Wir beginnen mit einem ähnlichen Beispiel wie zuvor. Wieder ist n gleich 128, aber diesmal ist die
Anzahl der Lösungen s gleich vier statt eins. Wieder können wir Theta und T berechnen, und
wir erhalten, dass Theta ungefähr 0,1777 oder etwas mehr als 10° beträgt, und T ist
diesmal vier. Der Winkel ist also ungefähr doppelt so groß wie im vorherigen Beispiel, und T ist halb so groß wie
zuvor. Wir können wie vorhin eine Abbildung zeichnen. Hier ist, wo wir
beginnen. Hier ist eine Iteration, zwei, drei und vier. Diesmal sind wir sehr nahe an K
A1, und die Wahrscheinlichkeit, diesmal eine Lösung zu erhalten, beträgt mehr als
99,9 %. Aber wenn wir es nicht besser wüssten und dächten, es gäbe nur eine Lösung, würden wir T gleich 8 wählen, wie
zuvor, fast komplett bis zu negativem K a0 rotieren, und das würde zu einer sehr kleinen Wahrscheinlichkeit des
Erfolgs führen. Das ist also ein weiteres Beispiel dafür, dass es gute und schlechte Wahlen von T gibt, und hier sehen wir,
dass eine gute Wahl für s gleich 1 sich als sehr schlechte Wahl für s gleich 4 herausstellt. Aber angenommen, wir kennen s
im Voraus und wählen T gemäß unserer Spezifikation, dann stellt sich heraus, dass Grovers Algorithmus eine Lösung
mit einer Wahrscheinlichkeit von mindestens 1 - s/n findet, und oft wird sie viel größer als das sein. Es gilt außerdem mindestens s/N, aber
das ist eigentlich viel weniger interessant. Interessanter ist, dass je kleiner der Bruch s/N wird, die Schranke
für die Erfolgswahrscheinlichkeit immer näher an eins heranrückt. Wie ich bereits mehrfach bemerkt habe,
mal die Zahl T repräsentiert nicht nur die Anzahl der Iterationen der Grover-Operation, die wir durchführen, sondern auch die Anzahl
der Anfragen, die wir stellen – also wie hängt diese Zahl von s und
n ab? Fangen wir zunächst mit der Tatsache an, dass der inverse Sinus von X immer mindestens X ist, vorausgesetzt, X liegt zwischen 0 und 1
Das lässt sich ziemlich leicht zeigen, wenn du zufällig die Taylor-Reihe für die inverse Sinusfunktion kennst, aber es gibt auch andere Möglichkeiten, dies zu begründen, und wir werden das
einfach als gegeben hinnehmen, weil es stimmt. Das bedeutet, dass Theta mindestens die Quadratwurzel aus s/
n ist, und folglich ist T höchstens π/4 mal die Wurzel aus n/
s. Das ist also sogar noch besser als Big-O von Wurzel n – je größer s im
Vergleich zu n ist, desto weniger Anfragen müssen wir stellen, und gewissermaßen ist es nicht überraschend, dass dieser Bruch so auftaucht,
da sein Kehrwert Theta definiert, und am Ende des Tages ist Theta wirklich alles, was für
diese Analyse zählt. Wie wir gerade gesehen haben, funktioniert Grovers Algorithmus ziemlich gut, wenn wir
im Voraus wissen, wie viele Lösungen es gibt – aber was, wenn wir nicht wissen, wie viele Lösungen es
gibt? Es gibt einen ziemlich einfachen Ansatz, und der besteht darin, die Anzahl der Iterationen
zufällig zu wählen – konkret erweist sich die gleichmäßig zufällige Wahl von T zwischen 1 und dem Abrunden von π/4 mal Wurzel n als
ziemlich gute Methode. Das obere Ende dieses Bereichs entspricht ungefähr der Anzahl von Anfragen, die wir für die eindeutige Suche wählen würden, und tatsächlich
ist es in den meisten Fällen genau die richtige Zahl – nämlich dann, wenn der Winkel Theta so klein wie möglich ist, ausgenommen
den trivialen Fall, wenn es keine Lösungen gibt. Die Idee hierbei ist, dass wir anstatt unseren Zustandsvektor sorgfältig auf
K A1 auszurichten, wie wir es taten, als wir wussten, wie viele Lösungen es gab, im Grunde um einen zufälligen Winkel rotieren, als würden wir
dem Zustandsvektor einen zufälligen Dreh geben. Falls es zufällig nur eine Lösung gibt, könnte unser zufälliger Dreh den
Zustandsvektor nahe an K A1 schieben, aber er könnte auch nur teilweise dorthin gelangen. Und wenn es zufällig viele Lösungen gibt, dann
könnte unser zufälliger Dreh den Zustandsvektor potenziell mehrmals um den Kreis schicken, sodass wir nicht erwarten, dass dies
eine Lösung mit einer Wahrscheinlichkeit nahe 1 offenbart. Aber die Chance, dass dies zu einer Lösung führt, wenn es eine gibt, erweist sich als
ziemlich gut – sie beträgt immer mindestens 40%. Das ist nicht offensichtlich, aber es ist so.
Es ist allerdings auch nicht wirklich überraschend, weil ein wirklich zufälliger Winkel eine 50%-Chance hätte, eine
Lösung zu finden. 40% ist nicht schlecht, und denk daran, dass wir die Wahrscheinlichkeit, eine Lösung zu finden, immer erhöhen können, indem wir
den Prozess wiederholen und T dabei jedes Mal unabhängig wählen. Dadurch sinkt die Chance, keine
Lösung zu finden, wenn es eine gibt, exponentiell mit der Anzahl der Wiederholungen. Wenn wir also eine 99%ige
Chance haben wollen, eine Lösung zu finden, können wir diesen einfachen Ansatz 10 Mal durchführen, wieder mit jeweils unabhängig gewähltem t.
Falls wir keine Lösung finden, geben wir natürlich „Keine Lösungen" aus. Wenn es keine Lösungen gibt,
werden wir keine finden, und in diesem Fall geben wir immer die richtige Antwort aus, nämlich „Keine Lösungen". Wenn es Lösungen gibt,
könnten wir es versäumen, eine zu finden, und fälschlicherweise erklären, dass es keine Lösungen gibt – aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit dafür kann sehr gering gemacht werden.
Außerdem haben wir, wie ich vor einigen Momenten erwähnt habe, dass dies eine Anzahl von Anfragen oder Auswertungen von f erfordert, die Big-O von Wurzel
n beträgt. Also können wir mit Grovers Algorithmus das Suchproblem mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit und Big-O von Wurzel n
Anfragen lösen, auch wenn wir im Voraus nicht wissen, wie viele Lösungen es gibt. Es gibt auch einen ausgefeilteren
Ansatz, der zu einer Reduzierung der Anzahl von Anfragen führen kann, wenn die Anzahl der Lösungen wächst. Ich werde ihn jedoch nicht im
Detail beschreiben, sondern mich stattdessen auf die Hauptidee konzentrieren. Wir starten mit dem Großbuchstaben T gleich
1. Dann führen wir Grovers Algorithmus für eine zufällige Anzahl von Iterationen durch, wobei die Obergrenze T ist. Also beim
ersten Mal, wenn wir zu Schritt 2 kommen, führen wir Grovers Algorithmus mit einer Iteration durch, aber T wird
größer werden. Wenn wir eine Lösung finden, geben wir diese Lösung aus und stoppen. Wenn wir keine Lösung finden, machen wir t
größer und versuchen es erneut. Und irgendwann, bevor T zu groß wird, beenden wir den Prozess und
erklären, dass es keine Lösungen gibt. Es ist dieselbe Grundidee wie beim einfachen Ansatz, bei dem wir dem
Zustandsvektor im Wesentlichen zufällige Drehungen geben – aber hier beginnen wir zuerst mit leichteren Drehungen, wenn T
klein ist, für den Fall, dass es viele Lösungen gibt. Auf diese Weise verschwenden wir keine Anfragen damit, den Zustand im Kreis zu drehen,
indem wir zu stark drehen. Aber wenn es nicht funktioniert, bedeutet das, dass wir keine Lösung finden, versuchen wir es erneut
und drehen etwas stärker – oder möglicherweise etwas stärker. Damit das funktioniert, muss die
Zuwachsrate von T sorgfältig gewählt werden. Eine Möglichkeit, dies zu realisieren, besteht darin, T durch das Aufrunden von 6/5 mal T zu ersetzen.
T wird also exponentiell erhöht, und intuitiv können wir uns vorstellen, dass wir jedes Mal 25% stärker drehen.
Und es ist wichtig für die Analyse, dass t exponentiell so zunimmt. Warum 6/5, könnte man fragen – nun, es ist
einfach eine Zahl, die funktioniert, und es gibt tatsächlich einen Bereich von Werten, die funktionieren. Aber 2 funktioniert beispielsweise nicht – T
jedes Mal zu verdoppeln ist eine zu schnelle Erhöhung, um die Vorteile leichterer Drehungen voll auszuschöpfen. Auf jeden Fall ist der Punkt dieser
ausgefeilteren Methode, dass sie dieselbe asymptotische Schranke für die Anzahl der benötigten Anfragen liefert wie zuvor:
Big-O von der Quadratwurzel aus n/s – aber wir müssen im Voraus nicht wissen, wie viele Lösungen es gibt. Und übrigens
können wir diesen Prozess stoppen, wenn T Wurzel n erreicht. Wenn es also keine Lösungen gibt, kommen wir nach Big-O
von Wurzel n Anfragen zu diesem Schluss. Und so können wir die Anzahl der Iterationen in Grovers Algorithmus wählen. Zum Abschluss der Lektion werde ich
noch ein paar kurze Anmerkungen zu Grovers Algorithmus machen. Erstens: Im Query-Modell ist
Grovers Algorithmus asymptotisch optimal. Das bedeutet, dass es nicht möglich ist, einen
Query-Algorithmus zur Lösung des Suchproblems oder sogar des eindeutigen Suchproblems zu entwickeln, der asymptotisch
weniger als Big-O von Wurzel n Anfragen im schlimmsten Fall benötigt. Das lässt sich rigoros beweisen,
und es gibt tatsächlich mehrere bekannte Beweise für diese Tatsache. Interessanterweise war das sogar
bekannt, bevor Grovers Algorithmus entdeckt wurde. Grovers Algorithmus erfüllte die bereits bekannte untere Schranke für die Anzahl der
benötigten Anfragen. Von Zeit zu Zeit kommen Leute mit Ansätzen, von denen sie glauben, dass sie asymptotisch
besser als Grovers Algorithmus sind. Aber es gibt immer entweder einen Fehler oder eine Annahme über die Funktion f und
wie auf sie zugegriffen werden kann, oder ein anderes problematisches Problem, das die Behauptung falsch macht. Wenn du korrekt
im Query-Modell arbeitest, kannst du Grovers Algorithmus für die unstrukturierte Suche nicht schlagen. Zweitens: Grovers Algorithmus ist
ziemlich breit anwendbar in dem Sinne, dass die quadratwurzelmäßige Beschleunigung, die Grovers Algorithmus für das unstrukturierte Suchproblem bietet, in
einer Vielzahl verschiedener Einstellungen erzielt werden kann. Zum Beispiel ist es manchmal möglich, Grovers Algorithmus
auf einem anderen Algorithmus aufzusetzen, um eine quadratische Verbesserung gegenüber der Leistung dieses Algorithmus zu erzielen. Grovers Algorithmus wird auch
sehr häufig als Unterroutine in anderen Quantenalgorithmen verwendet. Als ein einfaches Beispiel können wir
Grovers Algorithmus verwenden, um einen quadratischen Vorteil gegenüber klassischen Algorithmen für das Minimierungsproblem zu erzielen, das ich in
Lektion 5 erwähnt habe. Und schließlich kann die in Grovers Algorithmus verwendete Technik, bei der zwei
Reflexionen zusammengesetzt und iteriert werden, um einen Quanten-Zustandsvektor zu rotieren, auf ziemlich
bedeutsame Weise verallgemeinert werden. Ein Beispiel ist eine Technik, die als Amplitudenverstärkung bekannt ist, bei der ein Prozess,
der Grovers Algorithmus verallgemeinert, auf einen anderen Quantenalgorithmus angewendet werden kann, um dessen Erfolgswahrscheinlichkeit quadratisch schneller zu steigern, als es
klassisch möglich wäre. Diese Technik hat breite Anwendungen in Quantenalgorithmen. Es mag also sein, dass
Grovers Algorithmus wahrscheinlich nicht bald zu einem praktischen Quantenvorteil führen wird, wenn überhaupt. Aber Grovers Algorithmus ist
zweifellos ein grundlegend wichtiger und breit anwendbarer Quantenalgorithmus, und er ist repräsentativ für eine allgemeinere Technik, die viele
Anwendungen hat. Das war es für diese Lektion und für diese Einheit der Serie, die sich mit Quanten-
algorithmen beschäftigt hat. Wir haben das Query-Modell besprochen und wie wir es mit einem standardmäßigeren Berechnungsmodell verbinden können, zusammen mit
einigen anderen grundlegenden Konzepten darüber, wie wir Berechnungskosten messen können. Dann haben wir die Phasenschätzung
und die Faktorisierung behandelt, und schließlich Grovers Algorithmus. Wie ich bereits angedeutet habe,
gibt es noch viel mehr über Quantenalgorithmen zu lernen. In dieser Serie werden wir jedoch in der nächsten Einheit zu einem anderen Thema übergehen. Konkret werden wir einen
Blick auf die allgemeine Formulierung der Quanteninformation werfen, bei der Quantenzustände durch Matrizen einer bestimmten
Art dargestellt werden, die als Dichtematrizen bekannt sind. Wie wir sehen werden, erweist sich diese Formulierung als sehr nützlich und in der Tat
unverzichtbar für das Verständnis einiger Aspekte der Quanteninformation, und sie ist aus mathematischer
Sicht auch ziemlich schön. Also hoffe ich, dass du mich in Einheit 3 begleitest – und tschüss bis
dahin!